And I appreciate you have
me on her to do it and I,
and I know I don't have a talking
point, I don't have a PR firm. You know,
we even taught before went on air about
what am I gonna you know, I mean Alex,
what do you want to say today so you
can help me get it out. I don't know.
I'm alive. I want to say a bunch of
things. I'm only learning how this works,
being in the process of it and it's
given me a much bigger view than a new 23
years ago when I first got on here
because I've experienced what other people
have said, bad things. I did
experience. I did it from a good heart.
I believe questioning was okay,
I was covering other people questioning,
but then there's a weird sick irony in
the media that says that I'm the one that
pregenerated sandy hook didn't happen
when I wasn't too then in my name
popularize it to a level of like they've
put out more [inaudible] gets me.
This is key.
Then before you invade a major country.
I mean this has been going on for
years. Every day the news, the print,
no one died at sandy hook. Alex
Jones says, Alex Jones says,
go to their houses and hurt them.
What the hell is it for?
It goes on and on and on and on.
Well,
you're thinking this because it's
about you, so because it's about you,
it becomes a primary point of focus
because it's affecting your life and it's
something that you're concentrating
on, but the volume is massive. It is.
Volume is massive because it's
something that generates interest.
This is part of the problem
with the way we do news today.
Anything that generates interest,
I mean if the it, honestly,
if the media really cared, they probably
would have never talked about it.
They'd probably would
have never brought it up.
We had real terror attacks in the sixties
and seventies that weren't staged a,
if you go back and look at him like
the weatherman and all that stuff,
then that and the government and
the media didn't cover it. Well,
this is a long time ago,
but they didn't cover because it gives,
if you cover terrorists, they
do it more. Right. That's true.
I was agreeing with you. Yeah.
Okay. That's true. That's
like in other countries,
they don't print the name of mass shooters
in the newspaper because they don't
want people to get attention for
that. I mean, some different cultures.
I genuinely,
I've known you 20 years or so.
It's like 1998 99 I genuinely really,
I'm trying to find the truth and I
realized that once I saw a bunch of
declassified stage defense,
like Northwoods or like Gladio or
locked off the Tonkin Gulf of Tonkin.